[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de france 24
españa se encamina a reformar y ampliar
la ley de salud sexual y reproductiva y
de interrupción del embarazo el consejo
de ministros aprobó el anteproyecto que
sería votado por el gabinete durante los
próximos días y entre los puntos clave
del texto se encuentra en permitir que
las mujeres desde los 16 años puedan
interrumpir su embarazo sin el
consentimiento de sus padres que el
seguro de salud proporcione la píldora
anticonceptiva y un permiso de
maternidad adelantado además la
gestación subrogada quedaría
explícitamente descrita como violatoria
de los derechos humanos otros de los
cambios serían por ejemplo una
incapacidad médica retribuida por
fuertes dolores menstruales sobre esta
parte veamos las implicaciones
es una propuesta transgresor a que las
mujeres han acogido con los brazos
abiertos el gobierno de españa ha
presentado el primer proyecto de ley de
europa para que las trabajadoras puedan
optar por una baja laboral por dolores
menstruales con una reforma dentro de la
ley del aborto de una persona que es
mujer de una menstruación que le impide
e impide trabajar o estar
decentemente en un puesto de trabajo ya
que una menstruación fuerte pues 3 algo
jodidos y puedo decir eso pues me parece
perfectamente es común que durante su
periodo las mujeres sufren fuertes
dolores menstruales así como síntomas
como diarrea mareos e incluso vómitos
incapacitantes para el desempeño de
cualquier trabajo la situación es más
compleja cuando además son pacientes con
endometriosis una patología en el útero
que afecta entre 10 y 15 por ciento de
las españolas como en el caso de claire
band es una entrenadora personal que no
puede trabajar cuando tiene la regla
manning and colleges fui a tantos
médicos a tantos ginecólogos que no
encontraban nada a pesar de los exámenes
hasta que finalmente después de un año
alrededor de la navidad' de 2021 empecé
a desmayarme podía sentir que los
órganos vitales me fallaban a field that
my back on guns and work failing mind el
lento diagnóstico y el desconocimiento
de la enfermedad así como de los
fenómenos asociados a la menstruación
son situaciones con las que el gobierno
de coalición de izquierdas ha prometido
terminar
ir a trabajar con dolor se acabó en
pastillas e antes de llegar al trabajo y
tener que ocultar que esos días estamos
con un dolor que nos incapacita para
trabajar el permiso será pagado desde el
primer día ilimitado pero deberá ser
prescrito por un médico una propuesta
que se espera que el gabinete de
gobierno discuta y apruebe el próximo
martes para conversar sobre este tema se
conecta desde la ciudad de barcelona
marta busquets o ya llegó ella es
abogada experta en derecho en género y
en salud marta bienvenida a ellas hoy y
nuevamente a france 24 las reformas de
la ley de derechos sexuales pasan por
muchos temas y le voy a pedir que
empecemos hablando de uno de los más
sonados como pueden beneficiarse las
españolas de la inclusión de los dolores
menstruales como una causal de baja
pagada y más allá de ese permiso porque
es importante este reconocimiento
hola a todas muchas gracias por
recibirme de nuevo en vuestro canal me
parece importante porque al final lo que
hace esta ley es recoger situaciones que
ya se están dando y que están
produciendo que haya mujeres y personas
que menstrúan que se encuentran con que
tienen que acudir al médico porque
tienen dolores incapacitantes o tienen
unas cuestiones menstruales que les
incapacita para trabajar y esto es algo
que ya sucede entonces lo que pasa es
que buscamos otras fórmulas seguramente
para poder acceder a una baja oa un
permiso no y también lo que pasa pues
que no siempre puedes acceder de
urgencias no siempre te van a dar la
baja etcétera la ley lo que hace es
reconocer que esta situación se da y
darle cobertura legal de acuerdo está
por ver por supuesto conforme avance el
proceso legislativo si realmente vas en
estas condiciones o se van a añadir otro
tipo de requisitos con lo cual luego
veremos cómo sería a nivel de
procedimiento de requisitos pero me
parece que a nivel simbólico legal es
importante que la ley lo recoja y luego
está la cuestión de que efectivamente
pues bien aunque tengamos trabajo y se
asalariados con contrato etcétera pues
no siempre las condiciones del mercado
laboral o la situación personal permite
a una
a esa baja y luego las personas que
trabajan fuera del mercado formal que
tampoco podrán acceder pero sí que me
parece importante que se promueva desde
el ministerio de igualdad que esto pueda
pasar y se dé una cobertura y se hable
de esto este regule además ver está que
si no está reconocido como una condición
especial que vivimos las mujeres cada
cada mes pues esto lo que ayudes a
normalizar los dolores menstruales y
esto no nos beneficia para nada no
entendiendo que los dolores menstruales
no son normales no al menos tan fuertes
y se pueden descubrir otra serie de
patologías así que bueno importante este
reconocimiento hablemos de otro de los
temas la maternidad que es ampliamente
abordada en el texto y se dejaría en
firme además la gestación subrogada como
violatoria de los derechos humanos usted
qué opina sobre esta parte del texto
a menudo en españa' menos cuando hay
debates sociales se plantea la cuestión
se habla de regular la gestación
subrogada en españa' la gestación
subrogada se encuentra regulada de hecho
está prohibida tanto en las leyes de
reproducción asistida como está regulada
en el código penal no entonces
seguramente sería más adecuado hablar de
despenalización pero me parece
importante también que este texto lo
recoja como una forma de violencia
explícita hacia las mujeres y en
realidad va en consonancia con otros
resoluciones que ha habido por ejemplo
de organismos como las naciones unidas-
con lo cual me parece coherente que de
forma explícita pues teniendo en cuenta
nuestro marco normativo y también
diferentes resoluciones de organismos de
los que participamos y que vinculan
normativamente a españa' esto se incluía
muy bien también tenemos los permisos de
maternidad se plantea dentro de esta ley
la posibilidad de adelantar los desde
las 39 semanas como quedarían las
licencias entonces y por qué esta
necesidad de adelantar en vez de alargar
el permiso de maternidad en españa esto
es un temazo y ha habido mucho debate
porque en españa' estos últimos años se
amplió el permiso de paternidad y esto
genera bastante revuelo había bastante
división en organizaciones feministas y
de mujeres porque se partía una
reivindicación histórica de alargar el
permiso de maternidad que es de los más
puertos de toda europa y en realidad se
priorizó desde ministerio cuando el
gobierno a largar el permiso de
paternidad que ha pasado a ser de los
más largos de toda europa dicho esto a
mí la propuesta concreta de este posible
permiso a partir de la semana 39 parece
que se prevé me parece una buena idea
porque porque por una parte estamos en
un escenario en que los últimos años las
mutuas oa nivel laboral cada vez es más
complicado se han restringido y
endurecido los requisitos para acceder a
este tipo de permisos del final del
embarazo cada vez es más complicado y al
final lo que sucede es que las mujeres
efectivamente pues muchas tienen que ir
al médico
y bajas por otras causas en plan pero de
la espalda no me encuentro bien etcétera
esto tiene una repercusión por ejemplo
económica a veces implica que cobren
menos etcétera con lo cual esto implica
darle un reconocimiento al hecho de que
seguramente cuando estás de 39 semanas
no estés con los mejores ánimos son las
mejores condiciones para trabajar esto
puede pasar y que pueda también tener
cobertura sin tener que recurrir a decir
que te duele la espalda o que tienes los
pies muy hinchados o que tienes dolor no
es claro pero sin embargo sigue entonces
españa en deuda con ampliar las
licencias de maternidad para darles más
tiempo precisamente con sus bebés y que
haya un vínculo más saludable y mujeres
más saludables que se reintegran al
mundo laboral de otra parte más temas
sobre reproducción las jóvenes de 16
años o podrían abortar sin permiso de
sus papás y de sus mamás en qué
condiciones se trae la reforma en ese
sentido
una de las cosas que busca esta reforma
parece ser en relación al aborto es
intentar volver a la situación previa
que había la reforma que realizó el
partido popular que también endureció
los requisitos para acceder a aborto es
verdad que introdujo lo de los tres días
de reflexión acceder a obligar a
información de forma obligatoria en
relación a opciones de si sigues
adelante con el embarazo y también
estaba esta cuestión bastante polémica
para algunas personas que es que haya
mujeres o personas que están embarazadas
con 16 17 años y que puedan acceder al
aborto sin necesidad de hablar con sus
padres
para mí está claro que esto debería ser
así porque si una chica puede decidir
ser madre con 16 17 años y
responsabilizarse de un menor también
debería poder decidir no serlo y luego
porque este tipo de cuestiones está
pensado para chicas para las cuales no
es seguro su entorno familiar o que
puede tener repercusiones para ellas el
hecho de que sepan de que se han quedado
embarazadas con lo cual de esta reforma
lo que busca es revertir esto e intentar
volver a un estado previo
realidad el embarazo adolescente no se
previene prohibiendo el aborto
dificultando el aborto sino que
seguramente se previene con políticas de
salud pública de información de
anticonceptivos información sobre
sexualidad etcétera mire si esto llegara
a término pues es una reforma que
plantea avances importantes en los
derechos de las mujeres y que podrían
proyectarse hacia otras legislaciones en
países vecinos e incluso pues la
discusión usted lo sabe se está dando
muy fuertemente también en américa
latina' sobre los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos de las mujeres pero ahora
le pregunto más allá del papel usted
cree que estas reformas se tienen
posibilidades de prosperar en el
congreso estamos hablando apenas de un
anteproyecto aprobado por un consejo de
ministros
pues la verdad espero que sí espero que
nuestros representantes legales hagan lo
que toca que es reconocer que las
mujeres de las personas que están antes
que menstrúan somos personas de pleno
derecho con plena capacidad para tomar
decisiones sobre nuestros cuerpos sobre
lo que necesitamos y lo que nos hace
estar bien y al final estamos hablando
de medidas que creo que tienen un
impacto directo en nuestra calidad de
vida nuestra capacidad de tener vidas
dignas vivibles y por lo tanto espero
que los órganos legislativos
reconozcan nuestra plena humanidad y
nuestro derecho a vivir libre vidas
dignas y libres las que elegimos bueno
sobre eso le quería preguntar ya nos
queda menos de un minuto de programa
pero para su conclusión usted es experta
en género usted es experta en derecho
usted es experta en temas de mujer
porque no se habían realizado los
cambios antes y cómo puede afectar la
calidad de vida de las mujeres que usted
menciona para hacer que sean españolas
más funcionales más felices y sobre todo
más aportantes pues dentro de la
sociedad
yo creo que estos temas empezaron
complicados porque cuando hablamos de
salud mujeres género en realidad lo que
estamos hablando son aspectos centrales
a nivel ideológico sabemos precisamente
porque nuestro entorno tanto europeo
como en otros lugares del mundo como
mencionadas américa latina hay un debate
y hay luchas muy importantes en relación
a nuestros cuerpos ya nuestras vidas
como día colectivos mujeres de boston
entonces yo creo que sí que es
importante que a nivel simbólico y que
fuera desde el gobierno se promueva esta
normativa y es importante que luego esta
normativa se traslade en acciones
concretas en políticas públicas en
políticas presupuestarias en formación
en dar impulso en forma a la sociedad a
profesionales es decir que se traslade a
una realidad material más allá de lo
legislativo porque realmente creo que
las mujeres nos jugamos mucho a nivel de
calidad de vida pues mire marta el
agradecimiento es para usted marta a
busquets el gallego en ella soy de
france 24 y también para los
televidentes que están con nosotros
todas las semanas sigan en france24 nos
vemos próximamente
[Música]